my name is Laura Stevenson I play the
guitar and I thing and I write the songs
in the band
Mike Campbell plays bass Alex billig
plays the accordion Dave garlicky plays
drums and Peter Nanao plays the guitar
I'm not going to sit here and Jake
they're afraid you are breathing yes oh
you're Agarn Peter decided to start a
prank no this can only end and I'll
speed capable what is our second time
going to South by Southwest yesterday we
drove to Brooklyn backed up the van and
then drove to DC and then reloaded in it
hang on the next day for a festival
and then kind of just stood around to
the meet and greet some really meet or
greet anyone
and uh now we're in ohio just waiting
for the next thing playing in Kentucky
tomorrow I write songs that are
influenced by the music that my dad
would play for me which was a lot of
Neil Young a lot of beatles the other
band members are bringing in influences
like Peter really likes Johnny Marr and
like mike is really into the
replacements and he's really into power
pop alex is really into like more kind
of like freak folk anti folk singer
songwriters and Dave our drummer really
likes pop punk so it's cool they
definitely helped me kind of like play
out what the song is going to be at the
end of the day